hey everyone bandit here today i've got
something a little special for you it's
um
it's a picture of what i used to look
like when i was younger wasn't i so cute
what's that you don't think this was me
back in the day
oh is it because it looks completely
different and is an entirely different
species than what i am
if you didn't think this thing was me
because spoiler alert it wasn't then
chances are that you've probably
wondered at some point in your zelda
fandom about moblins for instance you
know those tall lanky long pig-nosed
looking enemies from breath of the wild
used to be tall buff stub-nosed enemies
from ocarina of time or even the
original legend of zelda
you see what i mean it doesn't make
sense and this applies to several other
enemies as well like the wiz robes or
the piccolons or the keys and while i'm
sure that in the real world these
differences are probably just due to
different designers over the years
designing different things or maybe even
different teams entirely but what
nintendo and co have designed outside in
the real world about the world of zelda
has become canon within the world of
zelda that's how canon works if it
wasn't then literally nothing would be
canon so this begs the question of
course canonically speaking lore wise
what gives why do enemies like the
moblins look so vastly different
depending on what point in the series
you're looking at them i'm so glad you
asked i made a video explaining why
you're watching it right now so be sure
to like this video if you like this
video don't like this video if you don't
and subscribe if you haven't already you
won't regret it anyway here we go so
let's take a closer look real quick at
some zelda enemies and how different
they've looked over the years like i
mentioned earlier one of the most
obviously changed enemies is the moblin
which is an enemy that's been a staple
in the zelda franchise all the way back
to the original legend of zelda in the
beginning the moblins were somewhat
bulldog-like in their faces like stubby
nose flappy jowls and floppy ears and
big teeth the works but later on in a
link to the past the moblin enemies were
redesigned to have pig-like faces
instead of dog-like faces and they only
appeared within the dark world which for
those of you who know could have
explained the appearance difference
since the dark world actually changes
the physical appearance of whoever
enters the dark world but thanks to a
later entry into the series we know that
this is not a possible explanation but
i'll get into that later on in the video
dog moblins or dog blinds as i like to
call them made a reappearance in the
next game link's awakening alongside the
newer pig-faced moblins called borblins
and that is their official name i didn't
make that up which was the pig version
from the previous game a link to the
past what's interesting is that both of
these enemies were present at the same
time in the same game but strangely
enough when the remake came out for the
nintendo switch there were no dog blinds
anymore all of them had been redesigned
to just fit the pig-like appearance of
the bourbons and i would try to explain
this discrepancy stuff but
it doesn't matter anyway because spoiler
alert it was all a dream so while their
appearance does matter it really doesn't
though moving on the moblins from
ocarina of time which did not take place
inside a dream revert back to their dog
blin original appearance but yet in wind
waker they're pig-like again in the four
swords they were pigs in twilight
princess they actually they didn't make
an appearance in twilight princess in
skyward sword they're neither i think
and finally currently in breath of the
wild they are back to their pig-like
appearances just with long anteater
noses for some reason now the maublin's
name in japanese is actually moriburin
which is a combination of two words mori
and gurberen
which literally translates to forest
goblin now normally in fantasy worlds
such as the legend of zelda goblins are
a species like you don't have multiple
kinds of goblins within the same
universe except for if you're talking
about middle earth because in the middle
earth franchise goblins are honestly
just humanoid monsters and their
specific features like facial structure
body size and structure is really
changeable honestly if you're watching
the lord of the rings or the hobbit and
you see an ugly monster chances are it's
a goblin or an orc which is the same
thing maybe depends on who you ask
anyway the point is normally a goblin is
just one specific kind of monster right
but since moblins and the legend of
zelda timeline go from being undefined
in skyward sword to pig like in four
swords to dog like an ocarina of time to
pig like and then to doglike and then to
pig like again with a weird long nose
this implies that the reasons for their
differences isn't just evolution because
they're flip-flopping back and forth and
we know that the pig-like moblins can't
be just dog blinds that went to the dark
world and came back because the first
time we see pig-like moblins as in four
swords before the dark world which
ganondorf created after the events of
ocarina of time after which he got the
full triforce of power
that was sucky let me do that again
because ganondorf created the dark world
after ocarina of time after he had
obtained the full triforce within the
sacred realm and we see the pig moblins
in four swords before ocarina of time
before the dark world and you could say
that both boar blinds and dog blinds are
the same species but just slight
variations within the same species
because they're both humanoid and walk
on two feet but in my opinion that's
like saying dogs and pigs are the same
species because they walk on four legs
in regards to their taxonomy dogs and
pigs share the same classes but after
that they're entirely different
so literally dogs are as similar to pigs
as humans are
so yeah that doesn't make sense to me
what i'm trying to say with all of this
is that doglands and bourbons are two
different species of monster that are
both referred to as mablin and moblins
aren't the only monsters in the zelda
franchise that this weird species
confusion has happened to for the sake
of time i won't go into the same amounts
of detail for the other species of
monsters but take wizrubs for example
originally they were just undead humans
all the way up until wind waker where
they randomly appeared like bird-like
humanoids which i guess could mean that
their undead rito huh that would be an
interesting theory bokoblins which were
introduced to the series in the wind
waker were initially pig-like with long
ears and pig snouts and a horn and they
showed signs of intelligence with their
clothing and weapons and then they
became i guess just classic goblin-like
in twilight princess with hair but then
they lost their horns and then in
skyward sword they got their horns back
kept their hair and in breath of the
wild currently they have no hair with a
single horn and they're apparently of
lower intelligence because they go
around with just crude weapons and very
little clothing which is clearly a sign
of low intelligence and keys have
clearly lost something over the years
now i could go on to other species of
enemies but i think i've made my case
quite clear the species of monsters in
the entire zelda franchise have been
shown to be completely different
depending on what point of the timeline
you're looking at them lore wise i think
this only has one possible explanation
that fits every piece i just talked
about see some people assume that ganon
was responsible for creating all the
monsters across the entire legend of
zelda franchise this notion does have
some merit to it because whenever you
kill a monster it just kind of explodes
normally into this purple mist of malice
but personally i think it has a
different much simpler explanation the
terms moblin or bacoblin or even wizrobe
could potentially refer not to that
monster's species but rather to the rank
that that monster holds within ganon's
army the monsters themselves are just
simply different species of beings
within the universe of the legend of
zelda i would call it hyrule by the way
but there are clearly lands outside
hyrule due to several sources from
in-game content anyway these different
monster species are recruited and then
given a rank and title name according to
their abilities the foot soldiers that
are good at swinging weapons but not
much else are called bokoblins the ones
that are a little bit bigger than the
bokoblins and can swing bigger weapons
are called moblins the variations that
are dead and brought back to life by
ganon's magic or wiz rogue magic are
called stall and then whatever enemy
they are magic users are called wiz
robes and so on and so forth now some
enemies like lionel's for instance have
always had the same appearance across
the franchise so yes their species could
be referred to as lionel there's no
evidence against that but for most of
the other enemies out there i think this
rank terminology appears to be the only
explanation now i could end the video
right there and ask you guys what you
think about it but i'd like to go a
little bit further into the realm of
just speculation and hopes of what we
might see in the future see if the enemy
names are really just referring to the
rank of that specific kind of monster
within ganon's army that must mean that
there are some of these species of
monsters roaming around out there that
are not a part of ganon's army right
meaning that there could be tribes of
bakoblins or whatever their real names
are just out there in the woods or maybe
in their own little villages as neutral
or even friendly parties that we have
yet to meet and what if one day be it in
breath of the wild 2 or the next zelda
game on down the line should it ever
arrive we eventually meet some of these
friendly monsters and befriend them that
would be pretty cool and i know that at
least kilton would be into the idea but
until then this has all been just my
theory what did you guys think are the
terms moblin and bacoblin just the ranks
of the monsters in ganon's army since
those monsters have been shown to be
entirely different species across the
franchise or does it literally not
matter because it was just different
designers having a different go at the
same kind of enemy let me know what you
think in the comments below also thank
you so much for watching huge thanks as
always to my bandit crew who make my day
every single day and please say hello to
the following new people welcome to
george m eric p alex s pineus and gamer
world who have all joined the ranks of
my elite if you watching are interested
in doing the same then that join button
is located right below any of my videos
or you can press that subscribe button
with the bells on that's just as good
but anyways that's all i've got for this
one so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day this is
bandit looking forward to seeing you in
the next one and signing out
[Music]
you